[Music]
I'm ready whenever you are you're ready
okay citizens of the reject Nation it's
me Tera Ericson alongside this guy who
was just like I'm ready when you are
yeah man I'm Greg Greg out I mean give
me a break listen we're watching Lovely
Bones The Lovely Bones The Lovely Bones
they're bones and they are lovely I have
not seen this movie apparent It's a
drama I don't really know what I'm in
for except I hope I get to see some
bones how are you doing today Gregory
Alba I'm good I'm good I've heard good
things about this movie it's from
director Peter Jackson I think Mark
Wahlberg's in it really I think so okay
I love him so I'm excited yeah everyone
I adore him leave a like leave a comment
and don't forget to ring the
bell ring the
bell see how I threw you off the scent
yeah you thought I was going to go with
like a dark drama bones type of a song
but then I brought it back to what I
normally do because I keep you on your
toes thanks prep for helping us edit
down this video also if you know what's
good for you you got to get on patreon
okay you got to get super sexy cuz
that's what we call you you get to
seeing up with your whole copy watch the
whole thing with the me and The Lovely
Bones and the Gregory okay and also Greg
and John offer exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there so just get over
there if you know what's good for you
okay so we're going to watch The Lovely
Bones then we're going to get to it get
Bon and not between us with the movie in
three two
one oh happy feet that's cute I remember
being really small okay there was a snow
globe and I remember the penguin who
lived inside the
globe he was all alone in there and I
worried for him that's empathetic don't
worry Kiddo he has a nice life he's
trapped in a purse perfect
[Music]
world nice I feel like there's some type
of metaphor metaphor setup for
getting oh Rachel V Let's Get
It Avid Reader she is I know that's a
ton of books right
there oh God 12 years all
right she still hasn't cleaned up that
pile of books no after all these
years oh so she's in this s Ronin yes I
remember being given a camera for my
birthday I love the way a photo could
capture a
moment why is she talking like in this
past tense way that's what I wanted to
be when I grew up a wildlife
photographer oh she dead and she's The
Lovely Bones and that's why she's
talking the past tense sort of the
impression I'm getting right now yeah I
remember going with Dad to the sinkhole
out at the Connor's
Farm oh how fun and I remember the girl
who lived there Ruth Connor the kids at
our school said she was weird but now I
know she saw things others didn't that's
a very mysterious exchange there what
things did she see and I remember the
worst thing that ever happened to us as
a family lovely what happened he
swallowed a twig is his name lovely I
don't
[Music]
know
okay yeah all right cool car good
job watch
out this music seems very much in
contrast with the moment
yeah that is your daughter you know you
know that's your
daughter he
lived buly bugly
bugly
Susan Everything feels like a dream
right now grandma Lynn predicted I would
live a long and happy life because I had
saved my brother doesn't sound like
that's what's going to happen grandma
Lynn was wrong I am dead my name is
salmon first name Susie I was 14 years
old when I was murdered on December 6th
1973 murdered Jesus what this was before
missing kid started appearing on milk
cartons or were feature stories on The
Daily News oh yeah in the 70s that was a
big thing it was back when people
believe things like that didn't happen I
got to say man the production design on
all the costumes and stuff I did not
grow up in this era like you however
this does feel very authentic I'm
[Music]
28 he's cute does he like you as much as
you like him Grandma he's senior whoa I
could have played this guy you could
have I don't know his hair might be
better shut up terara you're 50 it's
full and it's curly and it's just sits
nicely there's no need to put me down I
don't put you down if I hadn't been so
distracted I would have realized
something was wrong but I was too busy
thinking about the length of RAC sing's
eyelashes oh my God so have you kissed
him yet kissed him yet has she even
talked to him yet I'm just afraid I
won't be any good at it my first kiss
was with a grown man wow this is a bit
awkward I mean she's a hot grandma
that's for
sure took me a long time before I
realized that a kiss like that this guy
looking at it's toally watching them it
only happens
once did she die before getting her
first
kiss it wasn't Mr owire by the way yeah
okay I knew it yeah he's in the story Mr
odo's own daughter died a year and a
half after I did she had leukemia but I
never saw her in my heaven interesting
grass of the world there is like this
constant ethereal wash over everything
yeah my murderer was a man from our
neighborhood I took his photo once as he
talked to my parents about his border
flowers oh I'm going to love it they're
like not going to show him till the last
like I was aiming for the bushes when he
got in the way he stepped out of nowhere
and ruined the shot damn serial killers
he ruined a lot of things oh I think
it's Stanley to I think I think it's
Stanley Tui really yeah okay I'm pretty
sure I saw stanle Tui in the
mall oh he he now has the H oh wait no
that doesn't make sense cuz I'm like it
looks like the house like the guy
brought that the big guy got for his
daughter yeah that I'm like oh did he
kill that girl but she died of leukemia
it
[Music]
says I mean he already seems like some
suspicious creepy guy in your
neighborhood
yeah why is he painting a
dollhouse oh God he's building his
dungeon
it's interesting I really know the Lord
of the Rings movies so I see a lot of
the flourishes of Peter Jackson's like
horror camera movement directing did Mom
know before she married you about your
Obsession Obsession with what with the
boat things like if you start something
you finish it you don't stop until you
get it right if you don't get it right
you start over again and you keep on
going as long as long as you have to
that's the way it is sounds like a a
theme of the movie I wonder what her
Heaven is because there's this emphasis
on like glass container like the snow
globes the glass bottles oh yeah like
she's stuck somewhere like she was
worried for the penguin yeah yeah she
was the
penguin Susie you used up all the film
do you have any idea what this is going
to
cost no absolutely not why'd you give
her the camera then you realize by the
time I see my photos I'm going to be
middle-aged no you're going to be dead
Susie there's so much emphasis on
certain objects I keep wondering like
what are these yeah are the other Clues
to
something hey
suie it's me oh my gosh oh my god look
how spiffy he is that's how he dresses
like a looking good hi Ray what did you
think of the more aello
oh it was amazing love that play that's
another thing we have in common what
what else do we have in
common what what the hell's going on I
don't know I'm confused how is he have
this much G to be
like crap I don't even read that well I
I
do he doing on Saturday this guy's like
something out of a novel it's like I
like him but it's putting me on edge
like why you are beautiful Susie s he's
like Dorian Gray not Dorian Gray who's
the guy from 50 Shades is he about going
for a kiss yeah that's what I'm saying
he even tried it earlier and it's like
too soon I'm like this doesn't happen
meet me at the mall 10:00 Saturday where
at the mall the Gazebo he just doesn't
seem real doesn't like that part of her
imagination yeah maybe it's how British
guys behaved in the
70s a she about to get murdered
now oh is she going after the girl she
just walking home well no cuz oh she's
following the yeah the girl who sees
things that other people
don't oh is this where Stanley Tui was
burying something oh yeah it looks like
the same ground
yeah that's the note from him right yeah
I think that's what he left in her book
there's this uh Fantastical element I
wasn't expecting yeah there we go I hope
that was your
homework oh he's creepy I live right
down the street how your folks
doing they're fine that's an epic Master
shot no you're the perfect person for me
to run into because I just built this
thing over here and I want to get a
second opinion do you mind taking a look
I have to get home I'll show the other
kids in the neighborhood they're going
to be very excited about it you are cut
running I don't see anything you're
going to have to be more observant Susie
God is she going to like fall into that
grave
okay oh that's a cool transition shot I
hate it yeah it's a quite a sensory
experience this is making me feel
[Music]
things pretty neat
huh you want you want a p job honey yes
h
you want to be the first one to try it
out really yeah sure yeah go
ahead it's a good performance a lot of
times these kind of characters I feel
like come on they're obviously suspect
but I could see why she'd be
[Music]
lured wow this
needle this is really cool Mr har yeah
was cool huh yeah I thought that you
kids would like a place your own to
see there you go set oh this is so off
buddy this is really uncomfortable
14-year-old girl knows how to use a
telephone not I understand I understand
I will deal with her when she gets home
and some games cuz I know kids like to
play games and then you know candles and
oh God is he going to like try to kiss
her and because her grandma was like it
was with a a grown man that she's going
to give into it I hate all of it there's
one rule no adults allow
oh that laugh got an interesting
delivery Choice Cadence in his voice
that's a cute hat I like that hat very
much oh this makes me so comfortable
would you like a refreshment
Susie whoa wow I have to go no be polite
you have to be polite be polite I like
that downward
shot I'm warm are you warm you can take
your coat off if you want uh oh God all
right the one safety net I'm feeling is
that it's PG-13 so can't go too harsh do
you have a
boyfriend oh I knew it see I knew you
weren't like those other girls shrouded
in darkness I have to go I don't want
you to leave like stepping into a
nightmare God I just want her to put a
gandle to the ground and burn it and run
out or smash the bottle over his head
but
a
dang
it yes
yes oh my God how long she been down
there
for oh the girl who's seen oh her the
note whoa whoa she looks like a
ghost I think she already is a ghost I
think she already died yeah yeah okay
cuz that was like she's I think she was
already killed and she just think she
got away yeah she's not with the stats
where are you going Jack could you just
wait Jack would you please wait for the
police stay by the phone oh yeah one of
you is there let him go man look for
your kid the editing and the camera
movement on this movie is just so
nonstop nonstop ma'am could you take a
look at this have you seen this little
girl sorry
buddy a this is so sad
oh yeah she's totally dead already the
first time she's run away she's missing
she's never done this detective she I
understand that I just have to get aess
she's not home and she always comes
home's going on here there's nothing
going on she's missing God what a
frantic ass situation it be in
dad
[Music]
dad what well he can probably feel like
her presence even as she's dead right
that's like a
thing so she's not in a heaven oh she
okay so it is like the penguin trapped
yeah like in the glass in the glass case
yeah it's like a Purgatory description
of what she was wearing yes of course
well actually I could tell you that
right now if you want to write it down
she was wearing um the best beanie
you've ever
seen the way the motion feels like
slowed down yeah without it feeling like
slow motion yeah it's fascinating and
she has a a beige
schol Mom oh it's almost like being in
another
dimension whoa what is she
seeing
him what's he bathing
hhm okay so she must like be really dead
versus versus partially dead like and I
thought like maybe she's in some
Purgatory or on the verge of
death this is a really interesting way
to portray this murder and her
[Music]
experience yeah the isolation of the
objects cerebral this of it
all he is exceptionally
creepy ah
anguish what is
that
out the beanie okay nobody yet you found
su's hat but you didn't find her which
means we really don't even know if she
was there at all right we also found
blood
[Music]
Jesus oh
God you were a messy ass dude he must
have killed her in his home there so
much
mud just come by the police
station oh he knows he's about to be
interviewed
okay oh his ability to capture
objects and make them feel so large on
screen little I wonder if if it's shot
on a wide angle lens and you get really
close to it I'm curious as to how it's
done exactly
like they make these small objects feel
very imposing yeah all I can think about
now is why didn't I see something or why
didn't I hear something because that
young girl must have screamed oh my God
he sure is fascinating to watch though
man he's a really really compelling ass
performance but you were at home that
day what day last
Wednesday
Wednesday what are you pay right he
still has the bracelet
again the
objects all little Clues you know think
the dollhous is little mysterious ah you
married I was yeah but you have kids no
I wish you mind if I take a look oh God
I make everything myself make all the
shingles and the furniture and are youed
stup cabinet making but there's not much
call for that these days damn took a
risk and tried something new and
discovered a talent that I didn't know I
had oh no peering into the window of
their souls what's that underneath the
stairs oh that would be the
basement
transition wow I didn't expect this to
be going
on life was leaving me weird that's a
really great way to portray like leaving
of this
Earth wait why is oh oh he's waiting for
[Music]
her wow this looks straight out of Lord
of the Rings now
yeah oh right
[Music]
whoa she going to go down as soon as
that bracelet hits the water as though
like that's her last piece of her
grasping to that was still there and now
it's not it's like a totem
connection quite appropriate for a 7
Days based movie to have the Psychedelic
visuals oh I think it's yeah
yes if I had but an hour of love if that
be all is given me what who is this guy
an hour of Love upon this Earth I would
give my love to the is this from a movie
this is oh maybe that's from oel yeah
yeah but also he still seems so
unrealistic to me I know he's something
else and I'm like is that is it going to
switch on us or is that everything else
feels like grounded in reality and this
feels and this one guy feels like
something out of some romantic novel
this belongs to
you I mean the school has to know right
where did you get this I found it I
write poetry she making her move she got
real close you miss her don't you she's
gone what if she isn't what what if
she's still
here you're not supposed to do
that what oh my gosh she has a friend
you're not supposed to look back you're
supposed to keep going why are you still
here who are you hly go likely oh she
might be one of the other victims of uh
Stanley tushi yeah this is in heaven
you're not there yet this place is not
really one place and also is not the
other place war from your
mind
well the visuals in this movie are
insane if they didn't win for like best
visual effects I don't even know but I
wasn't looking Beyond yet I was still
looking back oh so she's like a ghost
with unfinished business you need to let
go of Earth you're dead Susie you have
to leave I have to go
home semi feels like she's into some
like animated world yeah
Dad everything she's Tethered to is
being
destroyed I cannot fathom what it must
be like to lose a child my murderer
began to feel safe he knew people wanted
to move on he took comfort in the
thought no one was looking at him but he
would want to hunt again wouldn't he
there was one thing my murderer didn't
understand yeah it doesn't quit how much
a father could love his child there's
something with ligh houses too cuz in
the underground thing there was a
lighthouse and there was light going
onto a calendar and we were seeing
lighthouses there and with her that I
wonder if that will connect somehow him
to
[Music]
her it's going to be okay hey what is
that my dad knows I'm here I was still
with
him I wasn't lost or frozen or gone
who's she narrating
to H this reminds me of whoever that
director of The Great Gatsby and the
Elvis movie I saw Su she came into my
room she kissed me all the cheek a
little buddy I saw her too I think she l
i mean when you have a loss like this
you have no choice but to believe in the
afterlife she's used up all the we gave
for birthday oh is he going to develop
them all
now that's Peter Jackson there Peter
Jackson I could tell yep some of these
are good why don't you get them all
developed it's one roll a month thing is
is really crazy why do we want to keep
this thing dragging out like this we're
not dragging it out we made a deal a
deal there is no deal Jack a deal to do
one develop one a month with her and
he's sticking to it cuz he's still
connected look I've got a name for you
I've got several names actually Ronald
driver do you have an
address Len I've got another name for
you he's a janitor Michael gel I love
how Mark wre is doing all the work we
need to start working backwards you
start looking at Family histories will
you just stop it now will you just stop
I know it's been 11 months she is not
coping very well she needs help Jack
sure oh Mom send in Susan there's a lot
of like true crime stories that this
seems to sort of Riff on Lind honey are
you going to say
hello child hates me seems like the
daughter's preparing herself for yeah
your mother's in crisis your father's a
rat what does that make
you mediator I'm in charge
ho oh my
God yo this woman seems so
unstable
yeah
the dog
knows all right okay you're a salmon
girl right a my murderer could live
in one moment for a long
time he could feed off the memory over
and over again but eventually he'd have
to strike again when summer came he
noticed young lovers would sneak into
the corn field he began to follow them
and watch oh that is disturbing I am
living with this I am
dealing anybody CCH your things you have
a tomb in the middle of your house Jesus
guys you got to keep your voices down if
you seal it up that the Pain's going to
go away have kids who could hear all
this even though her mom is a drunk she
is kind of right my mother went as far
away as she could she found a job in the
small Orchard outside of Santa Rosa if
anyone asked she said she had two
children I mean hard work will make you
forget a lot and Lindsay who always said
she didn't believe in love found it
anyway I don't know why she care about
Lindsay and there it was the moment I
would never have my little sister had
run ahead of me she was growing up oh oh
my God that animation is great I didn't
realize Lindsay was thought Lindsay was
the friend I got confused by the casting
for a second oh no Lind sister I
thinking of the the friend yeah he knew
my sister had begun to wonder about the
solitary man who lived in the greenhouse
she seemed intent on crowding
him and he resented it well fantastic
Sean he began to feel a familiar
itch
[Music]
I would have liked to have kind of dived
into the family's grief a bit more yeah
CU it kind of seems like we just went
through some just show some basic things
of what they would do in another
movies God is he going to be in it and
that way he can save his there this seem
to be a sense of Destiny and some of
this those Roses are the Roses
paints that photo oh right the Stanley
Tucci is the flower guy so it's going to
make him think of that careful
honey that's why we went to that early
as and if that is her last role and
she's taking a picture on her bike of
that then he's going
to
the last person to ever
[Music]
suspect that was a fantastic look she
gave the way the water dri and like a
question of like am I crying or is that
a oh now they're all
dead
it's like he took care of those flowers
just that one day just a
[Music]
lure oh
interesting yeah what's the wood for
Buddy oh Mr salmon
hi what is that this just a project I'm
working on you're a
hunter ducks
H it's a blind right y so those things
really work oh yeah takes a lot of
patience sit for hours on end in dark
you talk as if you want to get caught
yeah I never got a chance to tell you
how sorry I am about your loss never
make the time never got the chance you
could always just walk
[Music]
over
is this really happening
no he feels
her just like he did when she was
yelling hey Dad look at
me the planes are
[Music]
crossing yo
conceal a bit yeah come on dude Jack I
think it's time for you to go home now
Mr
Sam dial a backjack go on
home play cool dude come on you get them
later both of you men need to play
[Music]
cool what did you do what did you do my
oh ooh you're father father put a hole
in the man's back door yeah he should
have put a hole in his head you can't go
around making accusations against George
Harvey when you have no evidence oh Leni
should let herself get caught it's time
to put this behind us this has to stop I
appreciate everything you've done you've
been a great friend to
me that's a very specific hug he was
like
yeah or is he just going to go kill him
maybe he's trying to convince himself to
actually move on no no I think he's
going to go pull some yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but he needs
evidence I don't think he cares anymore
I think I want him cold and Dead with no
blood in his veins look at what he did
to me what am I now the dead
girl okay
yeah
bro you cannot be walking in the open
like that you got to be hiding behind
Trees lead us right to your trap you can
be free of him but not this way what do
you know that man took my life that's
why she hasn't been able to move on
Dad Dad I realized what I had done I
will him to
stop what I willed him to turn back
how'd you do that oh realized what she
had done by saying she wanted him dead
now I'm understanding it instead of
saying she willed him cuz she didn't do
that
obviously God yeah all
right oh damn and now they're going to
think oh
oh God damn it
I hate
this damn this getting way out of hand
holy crap they're going to kill himad go
go go no you can't have killed
him it's interesting how there's no real
perspective in this movie yeah like who
brought him to the H Stanley did I mean
everything's kind of just on a I thought
it was all from the daughter's her
perspective but that the way they like
hop yeah it's kind of weird observation
piece yeah with like the dad right here
it looks like it's from Stanley's right
like I assume he's the only one
that it's like his dreamlike quality
just washes over the whole
thing all right I knew then he would
never give me up he would never count me
as one of the Dead don't you remember
the opening of the movie I had to let
him
go but you can't go until he lets you
go that's a monster esque camera
angle Sophie CET who
Pennsylvania 1960 she had been his land
lady uh okay she had been his lamp lady
land lady land lady okay she's stepping
into his
history that was that big ball that was
in the ocean earlier somehow she
stepping into his mind going through his
history Lana Johnson 1960 Bucks County
Pennsylvania she was the youngest she
was six oh my God Flora Hernandez
Delaware
1963 man this guy's been on the prow for
a long ass time Denise Lee Connecticut
1971 Denise leang like to be
called Holly one of the vi Holly go
LLY I think the movie is very visually
stunning and I think a lot the actors
are doing a lot of the heavy lifting but
there's something about the
characterization and the the way this
movie ultimately flows how it's just
kind of just been this one pace that
kind of feels a little bit Hollow to me
and I can't quite
pinpoint what it
is it's Grand there's a lot of fervor
behind the camera for sure but there's
something in the script it may be
because we didn't really get to mourn
these deaths or her death really very
much maybe in the normal way that we
would see in other movies so it yeah I'm
not
sure oh God is she in the
safe that would make the most sense yeah
would that's why the flower's in there
and he saw the flower and it's red
okay that's why I was a messy ass
disaster yeah would she still be in
there or did he dump it Susie sammon 14
nist toown Pennsylvania
1973 murdered in a room he had built
under the earth I man I do think this
movie is added strongest when it is
focused on Stanley tuchi yeah yeah well
I don't know I really like Mark Walberg
and his like I like that too yeah that
that story line this this like with the
grandma and the sister I I mean it has
to be there if Stanley goes to take her
it will start to be very engaging cuz
I then we're on the chase yeah with Mark
and him which is what I want to
see I was like I like the plane in which
the daughter's in but it feels a bit
Meandering in that story line yes you
mean in this one and no the where the
where the daughter is in the afterlife
or the in between she's kind of just
there to meander yeah it's like why is
has she been in the Purgatory in the in
point of us even going there yeah yeah
what's the
point what M's not over yet oh oh she
hunting what what what what what she's
hunting okay girl going to go get
answers
herself there's nothing I like outright
dislike there it's I kind of just
fluctuate between I really like this too
I kind of don't feel much for this if
that makes sense yeah I feel like at the
end it's all going to come together and
we'll be like oh okay
sweet
God I hope she finds the
book or the BRAC book of girls or the
little part of the bracelet the house
that he still
has
salt what the was that that was really
loud th what
the oh okay God damn paper
boys
oh God you left the cabinet door open
girl come on now
[Music]
yes where is the Book of
Murder damn it she can climb out the
window though she's smart she going to
find a way
out you put the bracelet his book his
book oh his I bet you guys a Keepsake
from each and every
girl the
book get it girl she going to see her
picture and know she's
next
oh she messed something up she left
some clue that she's in the
house oh salmon girl there we have
it
is that the king she's making this is
yes I think
so he's a hell of an
artist
a you don't like to see it dude I bet
you turn the page and it's her come on
now oh right the window that she
broke okay so he's downstairs good good
good good good D if I heard that I would
go charging up if I hear a Creak or
something damn it
can he hear that I
don't yes he's like a sociopath and he
now knows that glass is
broken
God damn it out the window out the
window girl grabbed that lamp and bust
it on his head girl run run run run
run scream and run scream just start
screaming my God she broke her back she
can't
scream oh my God oh my
God
yeah you show him that
book just this I was talking about this
movie suddenly got like really super
intense what you see oh my God I'm just
like
wow where's
Dad is he home from the hospital what's
going on is
he dead what's mom's back what are you
doing here what does doesn't matter
she's home where's Buckley he's at
soccer practice and I have to pick him
up in an
hour come on like now this Jesus Christ
there is no freaking way the time that
she would just hold Mom's hand and not
be like Dad I found the freaking killer
he has the hair in the book she would
this would not be happening this is way
too surreal no come on the book
you just escaped your your sister's
murder I know it's a lot but I think
you'd still be focused on that I don't
think that she'd be waiting right now I
don't think that this is very realistic
sometimes the Melo drama just like kind
of put things to a are they going to put
her in a point where now she's going to
go it's better for them to not know like
she's going to protect buch of
she's going to protect
them
okay thank God he's already gone though
right was about to get insanely
frustrating I was on the verge just
really like screw yeah you close huh
yeah too bad I was really hoping I'd get
rid of this thing I really hate to
inconvenience you but you look some
help God wouldn't that be insane if it
just
there goes the body be like I'm going to
need $20 more dollars
yeah I come here almost every day I like
to listen to The Sounds have you seen
Holly interesting how all these girls
get get like a shared Heaven did she
tell you about this place yes then you
must be ready I'm Flora Hernandez the
others will be here soon so they're all
like Tethered to him to his freedom but
he gives me this Skies the skies why
12 you behave weird not me I'm
[Music]
normal oh wow all those things that we
saw when she was walking in this
environment the Hat flew by her the ball
was in the
ocean yeah it's all of these all the
victim props
from
[Music]
is it time for them to move on I don't
know but it's sad it's
beautiful of course it's
beautiful it's
Heaven let's go I got
to what are you waiting for you're free
something pull her back yeah it's not
time yet yet for her to move
on
Ray everyone get in tune with your
feelings trust your feelings
yeah
H
Ruth did she possess her body what did
she inhabit her body oh cuz she was
walking towards her and then
oh wa
wa you wrote me a poem once you called
yourself
[Music]
more damn how do he load this thing into
the truck
yeah kiss
me a she never got her a kiss when she
was
[Music]
alive man what the hell is going to
happen son of a
okay you're
beautiful7 they at least have the book
and the evidence and the hair they're at
his house maybe they don't need the
safe in the
body these were The Lovely Bones that
had grown around my absence
oh sometimes made at Great cost but
often
magnificent wow and I began to see
things in a way that let me hold the
world without me in it fascinating you
looking for a ride no undercover pretty
cold out here I'll take you wherever you
want to go I'm not interested okay maybe
he comes after she throws him off that
Cliff young lady alone at night not safe
didn't you hear me piss off make him mad
shove him off the
cliff no way oh right in the Noggin oh
yes oh dang it Oh I thought I would like
stab I thought I was going to kill him
there is oh yay
see you later dumb dumb fate there is a
des he's the single he's the safe oh my
God Karma oh my God
o when my mother came to my room I
realized that all this time i' had been
waiting for her I was afraid she
wouldn't come I love you Susie I love
you too my name is salmon like the fish
first named Susie I was 14 years old
when I was murdered on December 6th 1973
we're shooting this on December
6 oh my God what the hell that's
[Music]
crazy
weird also that camera looked like a
lighthouse at the end with that it was
like a
lighthouse I'm thinking the same think
to
dude wow okay listen wow um I'm going to
get right into it I really if you're
listening on Apple and Spotify R riew
rate and review if you're on Apple or
Spotify rate and review please are you
not are you remembering to say this when
I'm not next to you Tara no I am not I
definitely did not say it for Planet of
the Apes but um I'll say it now in case
wants to cut from this and put it in if
you're listening on Apple or Spotify
right and
review um this
was a really
gripping and thrilling adventure except
for some parts that I was like except
for what's going on here and why is it
taking so long and you heard well both
of us yelling about why is she delaying
this she just found out the murderer
like what in what in the world is
happening um I also I I really listen
number one if they didn't win for
special best visual effects I don't know
what's wrong with people I'll look it up
that was some of the most amazing visual
effects and the fact that when we see
her walking and it becomes very ethereal
we're not quite sure what all those
props and the hats and the ball and the
ocean means until the very end and the
very end when they say she's ready and
she hugs that little girl I was like I
was about to start sobbing because it's
just it's so
Bittersweet uh and that did not win any
awards but Stanley Tucci was nominated
for best supporting actor oh yeah I mean
you got to give it to the guy he was he
was thrilling and so so good the one
thing I will just say and then I'll let
you get into it is that Mark Walberg I'm
sad that Mark walberg's character the
dad didn't get into it with Stanley Tui
like I wanted to see him get a little
bit of Vengeance on him maybe not kill
him but like all why is the book out the
police go to the house and I'm like he
just gets to escape for that long he
wasn't even in a disguise when he goes
to ask that girl if she wants a ride I'm
like I guess that's the 70s you can just
drive away and keep driving and I don't
know they don't know how to put a APB
out anyway um I like the movie go go
ahead get into it I just read a fun fact
wow what is it Ryan Gosling was
originally cast as the dad and he made
uh if I speedread this fact quickly
enough is that he was originally cast
but he ended up gaining a bunch of
weight for the role oh without
consulting Peter Jackson oh and Peter
was like we can't Peter was like we
don't want your fat ass around
here he didn't say that but I think
Brian go had a completely different
direction on what he thought with the of
the character I would have very much
kind of agreed with that I would with
Peter Jackson or Gosling no Gosling
gaining weight to be the dad character
CU I was like this guy looks incredible
for I think I said some comment about
like for a grieving Daddy he always
looked like picturesque perfect all the
time he did and it was kind of
distracting to me CU you would think you
would have been a tad disheveled I agree
other than once in a while just having
his bewildered Mark Wahlberg look yeah I
mean he's a dad with three children he's
going to be overweight and look a little
more tired than what Mark does whil
dealing with this grief I don't think he
would have remained in this shape but
yeah that was uh that was interest so he
was actually like go and then replac in
Mark walber who I mean Mark did a great
job but I would have I don't know what
he was thinking about being like no the
dad can't be fat I'm like he's got three
kids in a tiing life he would apparently
he gained like 30 pounds or something
yeah that's crazy and then he has to
lose it then he has to lose it and he
gain it all for
nothing oh wow uh yeah so The Lovely
Bones was not about um I mean it was it
was dual meaning bones meaning her bones
reside here mhm but it's also about the
memory love and connections that form o
with the surrounding people yes uh
around the the L of the loved one yeah I
also think The Lovely Bones refers to
all those the girls who are in heaven I
mean that's connection once they were
all connected and met in heaven I was
like those are The Lovely Bones yeah
yeah now it it was um sentimental and
horrific uh it seemed to like kind of
hover between the two and to me like
there's there's a lot of pros and
there's some things that I didn't quite
with uh ultimately I think by the end
but there's a lot of things that I
really did enjoy about it so yeah well
what's the things you didn't gel with
come on share let's focus on the good
stuff first okay let's get to the good
then that way all that will get ignored
by the time I talk about things that I
was like not quite fully on board with
yeah um I okay first off goes without
saying uh I mean we've said a billion
times already Stanley Tui was phenomenal
here like from beginning to end every
time time he was on screen he was truly
captivating and he did the furthest
thing from playing something that could
have felt like a very generic serial
killer performance he brought like ad
depth and believability to the point
where you could understand why someone
would conf would trust him as opposed to
playing up like look how suspicious I am
you know cuz you got to be someone who
Blends in with the crowd you got to be
someone who can who whose lies can be
bought but at the same time he always
had this inkling in his performance like
he sort of wants to be caught because
there's a sense of pride in what he does
yeah also the concealment concealment
you're like bro homie yeah calm it down
homie homie yeah he was he went all out
on building the little underground
hangout spot for yeah just for one quick
kill but I guess one girl but it's
really smart because I it's like of
course a girl's not just going to go oh
look at a hole that you made I mean he
made it pretty he put games in and then
of course with that effort you can you
can snag a young one and kill him yeah
that was awful very awful uh s Shir
Ronin I think is a a phenomenal actress
and again she mean this was 2010 when
this came out and she's done a lot of
great work past 2010 and then but going
all the way back more than a decade at
this point it it shows like yeah she's
always been great always looked 15
apparently godamn young like she still
looks so godam yeah um that's kind of
it's trippy when you think about it she
looks so young still yeah I agree uh
she's just got one of those she got that
face where she's always got that always
going to look 15 years old or something
yeah and um yeah the visuals are are
awesome I love how they were
constantly refle reflective and
metaphorical allegorical to whatever the
emotional state was at the time of what
was the main Susie sammon yes of
whatever Susie sammon was uh
experiencing in this in the world of the
in between I think the performances
overall were really good right oh yeah I
mean everyone did a great job there
wasn't one person that I was like oh I
don't believe him mhm cinematography the
the camera work uh I think Peter Jackson
excels at really knowing how to keep
visuals feeling Lush and vibrant but um
he does it a lot in Lord of the Rings
with with specifically with the Ring of
making this feel like this little thing
have so much weight power and he does
that with so many objects to keep you
attuned and be like okay this this item
must be important for something uh or
there's like they can feel heavier and
weightier than than what they actually
are yeah you know and I think he does an
excellent job there and like I noticed
like in the the camera was usually just
moving uh it was always moving and the
editing was Bam Bam Bam and uh
production design this really felt like
uh they shot it in some part of town
where the 70s were still like just
looked this way stilling yeah it didn't
draw it didn't draw attention to it like
look Hollywood has created a set it it
just felt natural yeah I agree yeah with
the neighborhood and with the the mall
shots too yes um and like the corn field
even felt like old I don't know why it
just uh and and the coloring playing
with the coloring also helps I think
with that like desaturating saturating
different colors yeah um is is awesome
and the music like the sound it was
great I mean it added to the horror
aspect of this like in the beginning
you're kind of like oh it's okay like
cool and then you're like oh this is
like a horror film
yeah um especially with the angles that
you were talking about I I feel like you
I mean you guys can leave the comments
there's a DP in there that it's like a
wide angle lens and when you get really
close it makes that thing look huge and
we first started to play with that I
think when we first met Stanley in the
Trap that he has her in he reaches for a
bottle cap opener and his hand just
looks so like big against this uh this
little tiny thing it makes it both look
just giant uh which is awesome and then
we continue with that with like the the
charms on our bracelet and other items
that Stanley 2G puts a hand on get uh
blown out yeah I am conflicted
throughout the I I would not write this
movie off as
um I I I definitely think the was flawed
though like I thought it started off
very I'm I got like rotten tomatoes in
front of me it's like really distracting
is that the audience like what do people
actually think about this movie which I
find uh some people are like vemi so I
just got they really don't that's insane
there some people and the movie's grown
in popularity over time whatever all I
got to do is give our honest opinion uh
but it is fascinating to see like there
are some people who like really hate
this movie and I'm like I don't feel
that way about it I don't either there
are parts that I really disagreed with
that I thought was a bad move and it's
taking too long and what's to deal with
the pacing that annoy me well there's
there's 250,000 ratings on here and it's
it's interesting how they they all
fluctuate between one star and five
stars yeah so they're they're all o
they're all over the place and I think
that the I thought in the first half of
this movie I was like oh this is going
to be one of those movies I'm really
going to love like it it I thought it
was flowing nicely the way they were
throwing you into like okay we're slowly
becoming a little bit more dreamlike a
little bit more
haunting and there's and out of this
2hour film there's I don't know what
point it was but there it did start
coming a point where I did start feeling
like character beats wise everything
just sort of felt like perfunctory is
the word that keeps coming to mind of H
just throw the like Rachel wise just
like do what you normally do with
grieving mother uh in this kind of movie
just throw in a few plot points here and
uh even with Mark Wahlberg's character
to a certain extent well I thought he
had more flesh on the meat more than
other people no puns intended there well
I thought there was a little bit more to
unpack with him still kind of the same
thing and I I sort of felt like they
were doing that with a lot of their
characters where everything sort of felt
like surface level where depth was being
provided by actors trying to bring depth
but writing was not really providing the
depth I thought this movie was a tad
bloated with everything they were
wanting to accomplish like we want to
tell something that feels um that
hearkens to like the the the the the
rise of like crime incidences that were
happening with serial killers and
children and in like the 60s and 70s and
to that story and I actually thought
that's when the movie was doing its best
when it was doing the things that we
don't associate with Peter Jackson of
just like this immediate yeah story
about daugh about girl killed and and
and and focusing on that story and then
and then it was doing like the dreamlike
stuff and a lot of it felt like they
were again it was just a little
convoluted where nothing really not I I
don't want to say nothing a lot was get
a lot of the emotions were getting sort
of
lost by masking it with the Fantastical
nature yeah like the Fantastical nature
while I liked looking at it it
sometimes the sentimentality of it just
felt like um a bit of a forced sappy
emotion and not truly genuine because
the characters I thought were constantly
kept on the most basic surface level
plot points where I'm like we kind of
just need to sit with them and I and I
think when it really started to lose
slowly started to lose that connection
with them was post her death because we
just started speeding through some stuff
and and like oh we got to establish like
the the the other world that she's in
but then we also got to keep the
timeline moving forward in the Pres in
the in the real world and I I just found
myself like observing things and not
feeling as much as I would like to feel
as it just hoop between essentially two
tones which was horror and
sentimentality were the two tones I
think they would kind of fluctuate
between yeah and what again like I think
everything on is like a technical Marvel
in a lot of ways and I think the actors
brought more to it than the
screenwriting did um at the end of the
day I can't help but feel that a because
of the way how they were trying to do
too much that things kind of kept
canceling each other out that I couldn't
feel enough for the characters because
we were kind of getting lost in some
other whatever we were do trying to
focus on something something else was
also happening that would sort of wash
over whatever would allow us the time to
feel or experience this thing here and
then it was just kind of lost in in in
the The Ether of things and I think it
would have helped to like latch onto a
clear perspective here or or something
cuz yeah I thought like the first half
half hour really solid like even a
little bit after she died and they were
looking for her body and stuff and the
way they revealed that she was already
dead um I like I was really really
digging it and then after that it just
sort of became like I'm watching a lot
of things happen yeah like I like the
last half hour sections of the middle
yeah I like the first half hour sections
of the middle and then the and then a
little bit of and and then a good amount
of like the last 20 minutes yeah yeah
but it's that whole it's m it's MO a lot
of act two where I I I just found myself
just uh kind of back and forth between
am I really enjoying this or am I
appreciating what I'm seeing on screen
the visual effects yeah because when we
get into the fantasy world of it in the
beginning is where we have a really
grounded
believability in the lives of all the
people in the script and we see them
living and even her voice over even us
knowing that she's dead us following
that story and it feeling really real
and grounded especially when we first
meet her with with Stanley and she goes
down in there and we stay there for a
second with the family of like we got to
go find her we don't really fully get to
experience the rest of that story before
we pop into Dreamland with the special
effects and where she lands um and I
thought we would get into it a little
bit more but it really just it it was as
if we popped in the Dreamland to show
that time had passed and I didn't want
to pass a lot of time in the fantasy
land I thought that that visual effect
was going to last for a moment of like
she's in this weird purgatory and
whatever but they used it more as like a
metaphorical statement of like what
she's going through and where she's at
and meeting this this girl but I think I
would have liked it a lot more to go
back into the family story of
immediately what happens to them and how
do they actually deal with it after her
death and then leading us to where we
see the dad with his candle and reaching
out of the window and and he sees her
reflection as though he can still feel
her just like he felt her when she
yelled and feels her in the flower um I
would have liked to continue that story
a little bit more to feel the the pain
and the anguish of losing a daughter and
losing a family member so that when we
do get the daughter uh because the
reason that the daughter goes looking
for that guy she already has an instinct
too so we're running off instincts with
the family with the dad and the sister
they all have this in in inct of like
this guy is let's I don't know
what's going on and then she charges
right after I mean the dad does but then
he gets you know beaten up ends up in
the hospital I would have loved to see
like what ha is it do we just assume
because the daughter is lying there with
the dad that the dad is beat up that he
told her I was looking for that guy and
that's why she ended up at the house
that's fine to assume it I don't like
Exposition but I would have loved to
follow the story more of like like dad's
recovering but daughter's going to
decide to take control she finds the
book and then like it just being taken
up in that story of the family going
what and the actual and seeing like how
they they run after Stanley even though
they they couldn't catch him I just I
don't know I really wanted that I wanted
to see Mark going after him even though
he did he fine he punched his wall
whatever and then the daughter does you
know she does get to discover him but
it's still wild Bonkers to me and this
probably happened a lot in the 70s that
you could be there's evidence left
behind and you can just keep driving and
not be found which is crazy and wild to
me but um I drew agree with you that it
it ebbed and flowed and I know that the
the act two is really where it slowed
down where I was like okay what how much
longer do we have in this middle ground
before we're like let's find him out and
how do we get to that story a little bit
quicker yeah cuz
the the the other world she's in does
feel a bit Meandering it doesn't it
doesn't really feel like like I like I
get it like that's the thing is I I
totally get it and I think you're
becoming a little self-indulgent with
your flowery expression of your
metaphors that we will eventually become
Crystal by the end um but it does get to
a point where it's like we're not really
doing much characterization here it's
not really advancing the plot forward
it's not really doing anything
you know and and I think that when you
get to like these beats by the end of
the movie with like Rachel vice's scenes
kind of accumulate to what 10 minutes of
this 2hour movie and she goes on this
whole journey in this film of
like I'm going to have a daughter my
daughter's Dead Oh not getting along
with my husband I'm leaving my family
I'm back and it's like 10 minutes of
screen time yeah and then they just kind
of Welcome her back and and I think the
movie The I get the movie's Point like
especially when they're explaining to us
about Lovely Bones and and again of like
these are the bones that formed while in
my my time being gone and look at all
the look at the beauty that has formed
out of pain and loss and grief and while
I love again sentimentality of that well
I love the message of that um I think it
does get I don't I don't feel like the
movie quite earned it and and I feel
like it kind of got lost here because we
didn't really truly spend other than
like scenes like like quick scenes of
like Mark walberg's upset you know or
this person's upset about something it
just kind of rushes over it in the most
surface of ways again with actors doing
their best to provide it and while
looking pretty it it doesn't qu it
doesn't quite get it and maybe it does
for people and if it does that's that's
amazing uh for me I kind of felt like a
lot of it was executed in other than the
visual language underneath the visual
language is kind of executed in the most
generic way you could sort of think of
like I actually thought the other
daughter was one of the more interesting
parts of lindsy girl whereas like she's
the one who's the family is is all kind
of a chaotic mess and she's the athletic
one who's staying focused and still in
pain but she wants to solve her her
sister's death or the mystery behind
that like her going into the house and
everything I'm like that that a great
plot point there but when you do get to
Rachel Vier turn I'm like I feel like
there should be more of like some type
of true resolve here instead of like you
you can't just have dead girl monologue
you know look at the beauty that form us
was like I didn't really feel like any
of that was really forming throughout
this entire Journey like this whole
beauty of of of stuff and the or or even
the um the gray of what they're talking
about of of like yeah there's pain but
look at the hope that that endured and
Thrive like really cuz I didn't quite
feel and unless I'm completely missing
the point Point here I didn't quite get
this like this this happy this
melancholic feeling Bitter Sweet feeling
that the movie was trying to convey at
at the very end here of yeah like that
it just did the the Beats did not quite
H hit it for me there but like I like
the intensity of the moment when the
daughter's uh has broken in but then
again like when when the mom returns in
the movie decides to like just pump the
brakes on this like intense moment yeah
like melod drama and and that's how some
of it just kind of reads it's like
melodrama without any true emotional
weight underneath it yeah and I the
movie just kind of kept me in Conflict
through so much of it because I was like
oh you're you're like you're right
you're almost right there piercing the
veil for me but you're you haven't quite
quite done it you're almost there but
you you keep cutting you keep once we're
at one scene we we move on from that
scene to go to your other the ju of
positions would not complement each
other some a lot of the time for me yeah
what I felt they they should have
between here's the very real world
here's the fantasy world and that's why
I think little things like weird British
guy with like feeling not real yeah
works against the movie when I think the
movie's trying to have like okay are we
supposed to see we are we only supposed
to be seeing this guy from uh uh
Salmon's girl's perspective and that's
why she's sees him as this dude out of
like a straight up like a fantasy movie
kind of guy and then other strange Girl
by the sinkhole um this movie felt like
it was trying to have its cake and eat
it too a uh a little too much like I
don't mind a movie that could be
self-indulgent or a little bit preachy
or um a little overly sentimental I
really don't mind that I can be a sucker
for corny I really can be and to me
that it I A lot of it was just ringing a
little too Hollow and uh but I I have to
keep bringing it back to like I don't
want it to convey like I hated the film
because I didn't and nor would I say I
disliked it it it was just like oh
whatever there was a great movie here
that I feel like I could have walked out
of being like this was great and
whatever it's flawed but I I still had
the feels and I'm like but the movie
didn't even really give me the
feels yeah it it did when they were in
the heaven part but I think what this
thing if girls came back when the girls
came back that that was great but I feel
like this movie played if you put
everybody in a room they were arguing
against beautiful imagery and staying
grounded and real feeling the actual
pain of the people in this experience
and then beautiful imagery but stay stay
grounded we we we want to believe this
the the I think that when we first get
into where Stanley tui's in the bathtub
and she's screaming and he's like dirty
that's as far as I thought we would get
of like oh this is a nice metaphor we
don't have to show him and what he did
to her maybe we just get to she screams
and now she's she's taken away and we
know that she's like dead and then it'll
bring us back to real life and what
everyone is experiencing but I think um
with the beautiful imagery we throw the
the boyfriend guy into the the the
whatever the guy that she liked that
gives her the kiss he is like a
beautiful he's not real and grounded to
me there's no one in high school there's
no boy who just like will walk up to you
and speaks that way and is quoting
Shakespeare and leaves you know about it
I just don't think that that is real to
me so that was the first thing that
threw me off feel real in this world
what it does not and the rest of it was
real and it was grounded with the family
until we got to beautiful imagery land
which I understand and it's as though
they had to Loop that in of beautiful
imagery grounded put beautiful imagery
of this guy he likes Shakespeare he
likes CFL he's going to he's different
but I'm like yeah but is he real can we
make him real so I'm not throwing off
the scent of like is this guy a fake
like even the girl that sees things that
are not seen she still felt real and
grounded to me like I believed it when
she turns around feels the the ghost
running by her and she discovers the
note that all felt real and grounded to
me I don't know why he was so aethereal
it threw me off a little bit but overall
the the special effects were were
gorgeous and all of the actors did a
phenomenal job in keeping it very
engaged as well as the camera angles and
the camera moves especially when it's
being handheld and a little frenetic and
then there's one part when she walks
into Stanley tui's house and it it seems
like monster handheld like it seems like
a wider like there's a huge person
holding the camera and the handheld is
like like this like it feels it it was
very it was something that I hadn't seen
before and I I like that effect that
they used they used a lot of different
ways to convey this story a lot with
like special effects camera moves um
music the acting the coloring all of it
it it's uh again like I said beautiful
imagery or grounded this and you kind it
was a little teeter totter back and
forth but overall um I did you know
really enjoy this movie there were some
parts yeah you heard me all about it
with the sister coming in and you're not
going to scream my my sister's hairs in
this book this guy killed like I don't
care that mom's back that bugged me but
uh apparently this is based off a novel
so maybe that's the way it's in the
novel maybe the novel maybe a lot of
this works better than a no than it does
at a 2our film yeah I don't know that's
that's all I got to say about it I
enjoyed it you already heard the things
that I maybe didn't agree with uh I had
I had a good
time overall I'm like a 6.5 out of 10 on
it yeah I would agree it's really just a
middle that threw it off because I was
looking at the clock a little bit at an
hour and 21 and and I was like wait this
movie is 2 hours and 15 minutes and and
I felt that last kind of that last hour
there until we got the last 20 minutes
was a little bit so six and a half is I
think is is a good one because of that
but it
doesn't just let me say that it doesn't
deter me from being like oh this is
beautifully shot a lot of good things
that they did and the actors I enjoyed
it but I agree with that that rating and
that's it that's all all right well we
love you guys so much leave a like leave
a comment get on the patreon if you
haven't already tell us how cool we are
we love you so much happy holidays all
the good things and we will see you
what okay danger I don't know what's
going on here I might not be here the
next video cuz he's got plans for me we
love you guys so much and we will see
you on the next one
[Music]
bye